I knew of this native carver.
He's a Kwakwaka'wakw guy.
He's carved a bunch of wooden sculptures,
totem poles and masks
that I have in my house.
And he's a very interesting person,
not literate,
not particularly literate,
and really still steeped in this
ancient 13,000 year old tradition.
He's an original language speaker.
And,
um,
the fact that he hasn't literate has sort
of left hand with the mind of someone
who's preliterate and
preliterate people aren't stupid,
they're just not literate.
So their brains are organized
differently in many ways.
And I've asked him about his,
his,
his intuition for his carvings
and he's told me that he dreams,
like you've seen the Haida masks,
you know what they look like?
Well,
his people are,
are closely related to the Haida,
so it's the same kind of style.
And he said he dreams
in those animals and,
and can remember his dreams.
And he also talks to his grandparents
who taught them how to carve in his
dreams.
Quite often if he runs into
a problem with carving,
his grandparents will come
and he'll talk to them.
But he sees that the creatures that he's
going to carve living in an animated
San soon as in his imagination.
And I mean it's not that difficult.
First of all,
I have no reason to disbelieve him.
He's a very,
very straightforward person and he doesn't
have the motivation or the guy all I
would say in some sense to
invent a story like that.
There's just no reason that
you would possibly do it.
I don't think he's told
that many people about it.
He thinks it's kind of crazy.
You know,
he said when he was a kid,
he thought he was insane because he'd
had those dreams all the time about these
creatures and so forth.
And so it wasn't something
he was trumpeting.
But I found it fascinating because I can
see in him part of the manifestation of
this unbroken tradition,
we have no idea how traditions like that
are really passed along for thousands
and thousands of years.
Right.
Part of it's oral and memory,
part of it's acted out and dramatized
and then part of it's going to be
imaginative.
And people who aren't literate,
they store information quite
differently than we do.
We don't remember anything.
It's all written down in books,
right?
But if you're from an oral culture,
especially if you're trained in that way,
you have all of that information at hand,
both.
So you can speak it,
you can tell the stories and you
really know them and you know,
modern people don't really
know what that's like anymore.